I don't know about you guys but the end
of this season Had Me Like
season four has come to an end and with
it another excruciating wait for next
season although a season 5 has not been
officially confirmed Ed Harris in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
stated that filming for season five is
set for April May of 2023. so stay tuned
near the end of the video for more
theories on where the show could be
headed now hold on to your pearls and
make sure to hit that like And subscribe
button P.S I will be covering House of
the Dragon next week we've got a lot to
cover dead bodies litter the streets
after the world has descended into utter
chaos last episode we saw how host
William used Hale's own audio
transmitter to destroy the very world
she created resulting in the host
controlled humans going on a murderous
Rampage William called this the final
game one in which only the strongest
will survive but as we'll find out later
on in the episode there's yet another
game still to be played and I'll get
into that in my season 5 theories later
on we see this fly hovering over a sea
of bodies a callback to how hale used
flies to take control of humanity a fly
is also present in the very first scene
of season one not to mention the entire
series here's a face we haven't seen in
a while this is a Rebus who you may
remember as a host whose storyline
involved taking over the Abernathy Ranch
in season one this woman is just a
random he carries with him a baseball
bat which I like to think is a fun nod
to the actor who also played Trevor in
the Grand Theft Auto series who used a
bat on his enemies now that Rebus has
been set free he's loving this world
William has created but that experience
for him is short-lived I thought the
direction was pretty cool here because
once someone is killed we follow their
killer over and over again until we end
on host William who reiterates the rules
of this world you know the rules
when it takes all in New York City
Hale's dead body is picked up by a drone
host where she's repaired quite easily
however she wants a stronger body this
is where this old host model comes in
we've seen Dolores use this in season
three hail wants to keep her face so
William knows who it is when he's killed
Hale's Command Center at the top of the
tower has been completely destroyed not
only that but William has a locked her
out of the system we can make up
Bernard's Body over here which has been
moved was he moved by hand or was it the
explosion would I find more Curious is
this mysterious second body there
certainly wasn't one there when we last
Saw Bernard I'm wondering if this is
Maeve either the writers are setting
something up for season five or they cut
some scenes which showed hail bringing
maeve's body up the tower and couldn't
edit around the body being there this
isn't out of the realm of possibility in
the season 4 trailer we got this shot of
Christina's eyes reflecting what looks
to be the Abernathy Ranch a shot which
is absent from the show likely because
it got cut I also like the chain link
earrings hailware suggesting that she is
not free she's always chained to
something a drone host shows hail the
recording Bernard made last episode a
recording which was meant for her
Bernard knew from his countless
simulations that he would always die so
he had to think of a creative way to
save the world even though he was dead
as we'll find out later part of this
plan included hiding a gun in the tunnel
at the Hoover Dam more on that in a bit
as we zoom in on a map of the city we
see Teddy and Christina among the city's
dead bodies these bodies are real but
she is not she's merely a program
running things from behind the scenes
but Teddy questions her idea of what
real means just because you don't have a
body does that mean you can't be real
Christina doesn't have a body but she
has thoughts are those not real the two
of them look at the maze which
represents a map of Consciousness this
symbol was used to awaken Dolores long
ago Christina thought it was Teddy who
drew it there in the hopes that it would
awaken her but it wasn't him at all it
was Christina herself Christina has been
the architect or Storyteller of her own
life in this augmented reality of sorts
in fact when Hale uploads her Pearl to
the sublime server that Dada reads
Storyteller so I think we can
confidently say the Pearl Hale had
buried under the map is some sort of
Dolores copy but how did this Pearl get
here there's still some debate whether
all the pearls smuggled out of Westworld
at the end of season 2 are accounted for
but we also never found out what
happened to the Dolores Pearl that
Clementine and henario would have taken
from the decapitated head from Musashi
in season three it leaves a lot of room
open for just how this Pearl got here
you might also be asking yourself if
Hale knew the this was Dolores how come
she didn't open the sublime years ago we
do see that this Pearl has the
encryption key to open and close the
portal between the real and virtual
world the answer to this question may
lie in what Hale says to William later
on in the episode that she had planned
to create a world even better than the
sublime in which the host from there
would make the way to her own she just
hadn't made her perfect world yet so she
would have held off on opening any sort
of portal I could be totally wrong but
it was my interpretation that Hale took
this Dolores Pearl and instead of
putting it in a body put it in this
virtual world so Christina was thrust
into this world with no memory of her
past self suggesting that it was white
but just like host memories in Westworld
those memories don't always completely
delete this may explain Christina's gut
feeling that there's something more out
there hence why she has this feeling of
searching for something in an attempt to
make sense of herself she created
friends through which she could voice
her thoughts these Inc included her
roommate Maya and even Teddy who will
find out is a merely dolores's combined
memories of him into a person this could
explain why he suddenly appeared at the
end of episode 1 because that's when she
started writing her story about a woman
searching for something the real Teddy
is still in the sublime where we saw him
at the end of season two so to put
things plainly Christina created a
version of Teddy and others to help
awaken herself as to who she truly is it
parallels Dolores journey of
self-discovery in season one back at the
tower hail smashes Bernard's recording
she knows what Bernard has told her is
right and by accepting this must also
accept her grand plan of a perfect world
will not come to fruition everything she
has worked for has gone down in flames
as Bernard says of Earth life on Earth
is a fire that consumes itself we even
have Johnny Cash's Ring of Fire play as
William drives toward the Hoover Dam we
know Christina's World which I've
suggested is some sort sort of augmented
reality is connected to Hale's device
here in the tower since when she stops
down on it Christina's World glitches
Teddy even says that Charlotte is coming
to quote take them out of her system
perhaps Christina is in this Walled
Garden that Emmett talked about a few
episodes ago but Christina will not go
down without a fight as Hale retrieves
the Pearl her world goes dark meanwhile
Caleb Frankie and stubs make their way
through the hellish Streets of New York
trying to make their way to Adina and
the getaway boat Frankie was shot last
episode and Caleb's cloned body is on
its last legs remember these bodies
don't last too long even Hale had a
comically large hourglass which
simulated how much time their bodies had
to live Stubbs takes Caleb aside and we
learned Caleb hasn't told Frankie about
how much time he actually has left Caleb
was never there for his daughter growing
up and he says the last thing he can do
is use his remaining time to protect her
but they have pressing matters to attend
to if they're gonna make it to the dock
Frankie needs to get patched up hail
makes her way through a massacred Time
Square her line look at what that
[ __ ] has done referring to William
just goes to show how little a role she
thinks she played in all this look she
made those Towers she enslaved humanity
and she also made host William so it's
kind of comical she's blaming it on
others speaking of William she visits
his dead body at the Olympiad building
where she says he finally got what he
wanted maybe this is why he let out that
small grin as he died Clementine appears
out of nowhere essentially telling hail
she's going to escape the chaos of the
world and find a place where no one can
find her it kind of Echoes where we
first saw Clementine in episode 2 where
she had chosen to live in a small
secluded cabin in South America those
pockets of the world where she could
find peace are inhabited by the outliers
thus Clementine hints that she would
destroy them hail meanwhile is after
William tracking him close to the Hoover
Dam where she sends a group of nearby my
host to slow him down among them is
Craddock who you may remember as working
for the confederatos in season 2. he's
actually one of the earliest hosts in
Westworld and may even predate the park
itself but William proves to be too much
for his assailants taking them down with
ease this is actually the second time
William has killed Craddock the first
being in season 2 episode 4 where he
forced him to drink a nitroglycerin
William retrieves some AR glasses from
craddock's Corpse where he has a brief
interaction with hail Hale's on her way
to the Hoover Dam in her EV tall or
electric vertical tank-off and Landing
aircraft it's the same kind of aircraft
William used to arrive at the dam in
episode 1. Hale confirms her suspicions
that William is off to the dam to
destroy the sublime but she won't let
him destroy that world like he did her
own because William's vehicle was
trashed in the attack he serendipitously
finds a black horse to take the rest of
the way back in New York Stubbs
barricades a local pharmacy where Caleb
retrieve supplies to help with Frankie's
wound after all these years he finally
gets to have a drink with his daughter
and I gotta say after watching Caleb's
handshake like this I wouldn't want him
doing any sort of surgery on me however
after Frankie tells him How brave his
wife uwadi was after he left it seems to
calm him allowing him to pour some sweet
sweet hydrogen peroxide over her wound
the two of them sing Que Sera Sera which
also happens to be the title of this
episode an app Choice considering one of
the lines is the future is not ours to
see it's funny to think that in Caleb's
mind it's only been a few days since he
last saw his daughter but for Frankie
it's been over 20 years of course stubs
forgot to check the back door where this
dude got in and mine controlled human
who tells him that even if he is killed
it's only a matter of time before
someone else comes and takes them out
and speak of the devil it's Clementine
who makes quick work of the two killing
our beloved stubs poor Stubbs had it
pretty rough having to wait for Bernard
in a bathtub for a few decades only to
die in a shitty Pharmacy it's kind of
ironic he dies to Clementine though as
he killed Clementine back in season one
for some reason Clementine puts away her
gun in exchange for a knife maybe she
thinks this will be more menacing after
she threatens to torture Frankie into
giving up the location of the outliers
but Frankie won't give it up that easily
and just as Clementine is about to go in
for the kill Frankie's saved by Caleb I
thought it was pretty funny that the two
fight behind a poster that reads
self-care Clementine is just too
powerful for Caleb and when it looks
like he's going to get his head snapped
Frankie takes out Clementine with a
perfect Shot Through The Pearl it's a
throwback to when Caleb taught Frankie
how to shoot tin cans when she was a kid
Hale holds dolores's Pearl as we
transition to Christina awaking alone in
what she calls the Walled Garden but
there's someone else here her roommate
Maya Who Christina created to have
someone to share her thoughts with Maya
tells her that humans and hosts have a
choice they can choose to to see the
world as violent and chaotic like hail
or beautiful and peaceful like Dolores
the world for Hale and Christina is the
same but the way they choose to see it
is different I like to think at the very
end when Hale strips off her clothing to
bask in the sunlight of the Canyon's
great natural Splendor that she is for
the first time choosing to see the
beauty of the world it's a tragically
fitting end for her character one which
sees her take out her own Pearl and
crush it William arrives at the dam and
sees that giant tear connecting our
world to the sublime for those of you
who are wondering only hosts can see
this tear as evidenced in season two he
goes through the same tunnel we saw
Maeve and Bernard go through last
episode and proceeds to the control
panel where he closes the turbines used
to power and cool the servers which
store the sublime we'll see how this
completely destabilizes the dam with
Sparks going off in the electrical wires
and The Tear itself glitching hail
confronts William telling him he's been
been corrupted but Williams says he's
just a better version a more evolved
version than the real thing when she
tries to shoot him William stabs her
realizing she's changed her body into
the much more durable exoskeleton the
two engage in a game of cat and mouse
around the dam ultimately leading Hail
to the exact location Bernard planted
that gun at last episode this is what
Bernard Menton is recording by telling
hail to reach with her left hand to find
something by killing William and
uploading dolores's Pearl to the sublime
she is giving Christina the choice on
what to do next goodbye to Lars
I made my choice it's time for you to
make yours I should also quickly mention
that hail crushed Williams Pearl but
knowing Westworld it's probably not the
last time we'll see him in New York
Caleb and Frankie make it to the boat
where Caleb opts to stay back he'd be
dead wait anyway she doesn't want to say
goodbye after all she just found him but
he reminds her that her real father died
long ago but at least he got to live out
every parent's dream to see their child
grown up the two-part ways and that's
the last we see of them Hale reverses
the turbines and stabilizes the sublime
that tear between the two worlds closes
and it's here we really start to see the
building blocks for a potential season
five the first thing I noticed here is
the aspect ratio signifying that they
are in the sublime Christina believes
she's here along with the other hosts
and it would make sense considering hail
just uploaded her Pearl to the server
the first big reveal which I mentioned
earlier is that Teddy is a program based
on all of dolores's memories of him a
program to help Christina make sense of
this world this is why we originally see
Teddy overlooking her while she's
sleeping and then it's revealed he's
actually Dolores Teddy asked Dolores to
seek out the real version of him to
forget about the humans the two of them
can live together in a world without
Humanity's flaws he goes on to say that
humans are not like them their codes are
written in cells and thus they'll never
change but Christina isn't sold on this
and because she's seen the good and bad
both humanity and the hosts have to
offer she decides one final game is in
order a test if you will to determine if
any of it is worth preserving thus
Christina's final game is the most
important of all determining what and
who will survive or go extinct so while
the real world slowly decays and any
remaining human or host Survivors die
off her game will continue in the
sublime Teddy disappears he has served
his purpose and Christina now morphing
into her true role as Dolores notice her
hair has turned back to blonde rebuilds
the sublime just like the original
Westworld this new game like Westworld
will reveal what will become of human
and host will Dolores become this
Godlike figure determining through her
Recreation and simulations if humanity
and hosts are worthy of survival the
prize for winning I would imagine would
be bringing them back out into the real
world to reclaim the Earth remember that
time works differently in the sublime so
Dolores could technically spend our
equivalent of thousands of years there
before making her decision and having to
come back we learned in episode 1 that
the generators at the Hoover Dam were
recently retrofitted to last at least
another 100 years with no maintenance we
also know that doors into the sublime
can be opened from both the inside and
out meaning theoretically if a host has
the proper key they could make it back
to the real world and shut off the
sublime for good the season ends back
where season 1 began that old-timey
piano playing the same song The
Westworld train this time appearing out
of thin air and Dolores walking down the
crowded Sweetwater Street wondering if
this time will set ourselves free it
makes me question everything we've seen
in season one could this entire show
just be one big Dolores simulation we've
merely been experiencing one of
potentially thousands of Loops created
by her whatever it is this acts like a
complete reset meaning many of the
characters who were killed off can be
brought back just how this plays out
remains to be seen but the show Runners
have stated they like to make each
season feel unique and it seems like
we're coming full circle for the show to
end with season five but what did you
think of the finale any big theories for
season 5 let me know in the comments
below thanks for watching everyone be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember maybe this time
we'll set ourselves free